Hey, I'm Nick from the
container tools team at Google.
And today, I want to
talk to you about one
of our newest and most
exciting tools, Skaffold.
Skaffold is a tool
that's designed
to make local Kubernetes
development easy.
It watches your local
application directories
for changes, and
can automatically
build, push, and deploy
your application images
to any local or remote
Kubernetes cluster,
letting you focus on
developing your application.
Let's take a look at
how to get Skaffold
running on your application.
Skaffold runs as a binary
on your local machine.
So installing it is as easy as
downloading the latest release
from the Google Container
Tools GitHub page.
Alternatively, you can build
Skaffold straight from source.
Skaffold uses YAML
configuration to describe
how your application should
be built and deployed.
You can specify one or more
images for Skaffold to build,
which Skaffold will tag, and
push to any valid document
repository.
These continuously-built
images will
be injected into your
Kubernetes ideas manifest,
and used to deploy new changes
to your cluster on every code
change.
Let's walk through an example to
demonstrate a typical Skaffold
workflow.
Here we have a simple go
Hello World! application,
which just prints "Hello
World!" in a loop forever.
We have a docker file that
builds a binary from the source
file, and puts it
into a container,
and a Kubernetes manifest
that creates a pod
from this container image.
Skaffold has a built-in
command, skaffold init,
that will generate a Skaffold
YAML for your code base
containing default values
to get Skaffold running.
Let's run it on the
code that we have here.
You can see our generated
Skaffold YAML has one build
artifact pointing to our Docker
file that builds the image
and pushes it to our
project's registry.
This image is tagged with the
git tagging strategy, which
uses the latest commit
hash as an image tag,
though there are several other
tagging strategies available.
Skaffold also defaults to
using the Kube control deployer
that deploys from our
Kubernetes manifest
to our existing
cluster, though there
are several other deployment
strategies available as well.
As we run skaffold dev, you
can see Skaffold immediately
builds the artifact we
specified, and pushes it
to the target registry.
It then creates a
pod in our cluster
using the image we just pushed.
By default, Skaffold streams the
logs from the pods it creates,
so looking at these now,
we can see Hello World!
being logged like we expect.
One of Skaffold's
most exciting features
is its file watcher,
which watches for changes
to one or more local
directories on your file
system in real time.
When Skaffold sees any
changes to your code,
it will build a new
image from source,
and deploy it to your
Kubernetes cluster.
Let's change our
print statement up,
and watch how Skaffold reacts.
As I change the string
to Hello Skaffold!
We can immediately see
Skaffold recognizes
that our source file has
changed and re-triggers
a build and deploy.
Watching the logs, we can see
them switch over in real time
to our new print statement
as the new pod is created.
Let's take a look at
a more complex example
to see how Skaffold works
with more realistic workflows.
Here, we have an application
with two services-- a web
server and an
application server.
These services can be built
and deployed independently
of each other, and
Skaffold is smart enough
to understand that.
Let's go through the same flow
we did with the Hello World!
Example here to see
what it looks like.
Running skaffold
init again, this time
we're prompted for
which Docker file
builds each image, since
there's no way for Skaffold
to know that beforehand.
In our generated
Skaffold YAML, we
can see that a build artifact
is specified for each services'
source code directory,
and Skaffold
will put a separate file watcher
on each of these directories.
This means that when files
change in one directory but not
the other, only the container
corresponding to the modified
directory will be rebuilt.
skaffold dev builds and deploys
both parts of the application
as we expect, and in the logs,
we can see both services
are ready in our Kubernetes
cluster.
Now if I go make a
change in the web server,
we can see Skaffold
picks up the change,
and only rebuilds
that container.
Skaffold's deployer
then only updates
the deployment associated
with the newly-built artifact,
and we can see this
reflected in the deploy logs.
This means your dev
cycles are never
bottlenecked by parts
of your application
that you're not working on.
These services don't
necessarily need
to live in the same repository.
As long as your Skaffold YAML
points to valid workspaces
on your local file
system, you can
use any number of
different repositories
in a Skaffold
workflow, making it
an awesome tool for development
on microservice-based
applications.
Skaffold can help speed up any
Kubernetes development workflow
by getting ops out of your way,
allowing you to focus solely
on application development.
You can find these
examples and more
in the Skaffold
GitHub repository,
linked in the description
of this video.
Contributions to Skaffold
are always welcome.
If you'd like to learn
more about contributing,
check out the
contributing guidelines
in our GitHub repository.
Go try it out for yourself,
and let us know what you think.
Happy Skaffolding.
[MUSIC PLAYING]